Texas is calling on private citizens to
assist in securing the Border offering
to dispatch free of charge razor wire to
any private property along the border
one individual said he's working with
CBP to try and stop these people but
they come anyway he said he put up razor
wire and these guys trampled over it
like deer and so he was just like it's
not going to work well they they they
scale fences they scale fences in
minutes I I I was talking to a border
patrol guy one time they had a fence up
and they had video this they weren't
there at the time but they had put there
was a wall in this area some sort of a
fence and they had specially constructed
a pickup truck with a ladder in the back
of it and a levy system and they just
loaded everyone in the back and they
backed it right up to the wall and they
just laid it right on there they had the
height perfectly and he said Jesse we
timed at 45 seconds there were 12 of
them over the top gone it's gone gone
put I don't know either like what I
don't understand either is what do the
people coming into the United States
expect like what what do they think is
going to be so great for them here the B
Administration is giving them $3,000 I
think it is and a free free free hotel
rooms how much $3,000 and a cell phone
they're chanting his name they're like
Customs and Border Protection agents
reportedly are handing three are handing
cash cards to illegal immigrants and
giving them rides to centers where they
get room and board and transport to
various cities taxpayer funded or NGO
funded those I assume it's taxpayer
funded
because they can't report to their court
cases unless they have the means to do
so which is the finances to live and
travel and the cell phones to be
contacted although their court cases are
if customs in Border Protection if
CBP just said yeah I'm not driving any
people anywhere then you'd have mass
load of people just sitting in Eagle
Pass you'd have you'd have six million
people sitting at Eagle Pass standing in
their own but CBP is smuggling them
across the country putting them on
planes bringing them to facilities where
they get loaded on buses or sent by
Swift there and other uh uh private
flights commercial well they're flying
commercial yeah and private Charter yeah
that's something I have confirmed the
existence of major airline boarding
passes that say no name given Ashley
stclair broke the story she uh she's
working on getting the story out I don't
want to say too much because it's her
story but I have confirmed that as well
as other
information that I don't know if I'm
allowed to talk about because it's their
story but she did say I want to make
sure you know this is real sent me not
only the boarding pass don't I'm given
there's actually a lot more and it's a
lot worse than people realize well it's
what we were talking about too earlier
is escalation now this is the kind of
thing that escalates the blood of the
American people the red States this is
why the Coalition form so quickly it's
this this is the kind of stuff that
enrages people at the same time the
Biden Administration this is their bread
and butter filling up the country with
illegals so who backs off and if you say
someone backs off and and I'm not going
to disagree with that cuz who knows how
in what way can you back off if you're
Biden you can't if you're Abbot you
can't what are you going to do say oh
I'm removing the razor wire then you go
from a hero to a coward in the eyes of
everybody
else St well with with Trump joining the
fry calling on more states to jump in
this this this is a this is not this is
a boulder falling down a mountain I
really wish that Trump had not because I
don't know that Trump making a statement
says anything is does anything good I I
think there's a strong possibility that
they try and call that an
Insurrection but he's a private citizen
how can you I'm I'm allowed to call for
I think the governors should send the
National Guard to the board I can do
that I'm I have the same rank that Trump
does right now right how could you I
mean I realize he's already on a bunch
of trump up charges anyway that's
exactly but it's not just that they uh
uh look what they're doing to Steve
Baker which I I think we're going to
have him in uh next week yeah he's a
journalist and they're trying to arrest
him for being there on January 6 why
because but because he's exposing their
lies his AC of Journalism exposed
perjury and so they're they're trying to
lock him up they will go after yeah Owen
they went after Owen Shroyer what did he
do he yelled death to commies no death
to tyrants was that I thought it I
thought it was commies I thought it was
death to tyrants because well either way
one of he outside as a private citizen
saying death to tyrants so they put him
in prison
can't they they the question is well
first private citizens can engage in
Insurrection the question is are you a
threat to the system Donald Trump being
a threat to their system they will say
he leads hundreds of millions of 70 plus
million voters he's the front runner for
the political party and he is rallying
states that support him into deploying
armed soldiers to fight against the
federal government that's
Insurrection and right before The
Supreme Court issues their ruling on
whether or not he can be removed for
waging Insurrection but he's not in
charge of them he's not in charge it's
not it' be one thing if he was a
governor it' be one thing if Abbott came
up and said fight the government Trump
is a private citizen right now but it
but it well I I should I was about to
say in law but like we have law anymore
but yeah it hardly matters anymore so
let's say um the head of the Teamsters
Union yeah comes out and says it is time
for us to go fight the federal
government and take up arms he's in
charge of anybody he's no
that who an individual that's going to
be leading some kind of insurrection or
Rebellion or revolution is not going to
be in the government it would be a coup
if that was the case you can argue that
if Donald Trump was in government in
charge of something and called on states
to rise up against the feds you could
call that you could call that
Insurrection two you could call that a
military coup attempt or
revolution a private band of people in
Syria for instance would like I I don't
know that Insurrection is the word we
necessarily need to use that's the
political term they're trying to use
but the the the the factions in Syria
who are calling for people to rise up
against Bashar al- Assad would we say
yeah but they're just private citizens
they're not involved in any way and we
should ignore them but they're marching
down the street with people behind them
it eventually leads to an armed faction
in a civil war so who else would you
accuse of insur
insurrection but this goes back to the
escalation talk we were just okay let's
let's say I agree with you and I don't
necessarily think you're wrong if
they're going to accuse him of of of
insurrection for this too they've
accused insurrection for everything else
if are you going to escalate it by
arresting him again for that well now
now we've entered a whole another realm
too you want you're going to go down
kick in the doors of mar Lago again and
arrest him again they are going to push
this thing to a place that I certainly
don't want to see it go to a free but
but that's the kind of thing they
will how's it I should say well I think
they would I think I think they would
there's a strong probability that within
a few months this is this is this I mean
look you've already got Democrats
calling for the federalization of uh uh
the National Guard Donald Trump issuing
a statement saying the FED is derelict
they're in violation of the law and the
states should send National Guard down
he is there there's no reasonable person
who's going to make the argument he did
not say fight the FED he like people are
going to go no no he's saying like just
to get rid of the illegal immigrants
he's not saying to go to fight and the
Biden Administration has ordered Texas
to stand down remove their troops so
they can remove the razor wire and go
back to but it was in illegal order it
was in illegal order the feds you can't
Biden didn't have the authority to do
that but but Biden does not have the
authority to tell but that's what I'm
saying it's an illegal order but so
actually he does have the authority no
Texas has the ultimate Authority when it
comes to that even according to Greg
Abbott Greg Abbott even laid it out
today he said we have the ultimate only
because they have violated the law in
facilitating an invasion but the federal
government controls the borders so the
river is the jurisdiction of the federal
government the problem what's happening
right now is the federal government made
has made the argument that Texas is
blocking them from getting access to
their jurisdiction the river Texas is
putting the barriers in their
jurisdiction Texas state they're doing
that to stop the migrants now the
federal government argued the migrants
are still crossing entering US territory
which is our jurisdiction on the river
but they can't get in because of the
razor wire so they're drowning that's
Biden's argument the problem is the
Biden Administration and Customs and
Border protection are engaged in a human
smuggling smuggling operation in
violation of article 4 section 4 of The
Constitution and I believe what was the
other reference he made was article 4
section 10 or was it article one I don't
remember what the basically the federal
government by being in violation of the
law federal law state law and the
Constitution Texas has asserted its
right to assume the defense of its
borders with the absence of the federal
Duty here's a question we're talking
about escalation and everything what do
we do or what not what we what do they
do what is the response if someone gets
hurt what if a border of Patrol agent
gets hurt down there what if an illegal
gets hurt you know how they already
cover every time an illegal God forbid
drowns in the river or something like
that what if some somebody pops off what
who knows what can happen what is the
response if we all turn on the news
tomorrow night or to hit social before
it hits anything at what is the response
when the media is running a 24-hour Loop
look this look at this person he got
killed look at this person who got what
what do they do then what they're going
to do is they're going to ramp it up
against our side no matter no matter who
is at fault and they're going to say
look now they're going to point to Trump
look he got this person killed look
Abbot got this person now that takes to
a whole new level once you have a bad
picture one bad picture out there it's
going to be
trouble Civil
War no don't say that I hope I I I find
it fascinating I find it absolutely
fascinating ating the people who to this
day still deny Civil War and that's why
I posted the y'all laughed at me but now
but Who's Laughing Now meme which is the
old man throwing the tumble weed in the
street and Family Guy and it's and it's
funny because I did not predict this at
all I did not predict that Texas would
send its National Guard to go repel
federal agents and that the former
president would call on multiple states
to deploy their armed national guard
against the federal government people
asked me if I thought it was possible
that armed guards would start marching
and oppose like the Federal auth and I
was like no no no no that's that's
American Civil War most civil wars in
the world are like Syria a a random
group of ideological faction like antifa
emerges starts opening fire police open
fire back like we saw at stop cop City
and then you get pockets of violence
popping up all over the place factions
then start coalescing into various
groups because they want stability and
everybody you know let's say anti-ub
makes a takes over Chaz typically in in
your average civil War throughout all of
history what would happen is antifa
crates chz and then the the the federal
government is it can't do anything to
stop them because they're spread too
thin or they're dealing with conflicts
overseas or whatever uh or there's a
lack of resources and enthusiasm in the
federal uh law enforcement side the Chaz
people start expanding control of this
territory bringing in shops bringing in
more people who now are are are asking
themselves who has the Monopoly on
violence the federal government will not
protect me so this person with the gun
is in charge that's how it works then
eventually when those areas grow too
large people are shooting at each other
and they're fighting to seize control
like antiw fighting with cops this is
how Syria goes Syria starts with 12 or
more factions eventually it turns into
Isis and there's just Isis throughout
the Middle East Isis was the dominant
Force took everybody over you fight for
me now so the idea that each state would
raise up an army and say we're marching
to fight the FED I was like that's not
going to happen and now holy mother
Texas is like you are in violation of
the law you are in violation of the
Constitution and our troops will bar you
setting up more razor wire as the day
goes on as the days go on tomorrow is
the day the Biden Administration said
was their deadline so what the
happens are CBP going to try and push
out armed Texas National Guard so this
can go a several different ways it's
possible nothing happens the Biden Biden
Administration says we don't want to
escalate this doesn't he have to do
something Biden has to do something
he has to do well AB can stand Pat no
it's ours can't do it Biden is the one
with an action item in front of him you
drop the or else then you've got to
deliver something with the or else don't
you so the question is what is that
something is it cutting off Federal
funding is it is it that would do
nothing I agree but it's something it
gives him a win I cut off their Federal
funding no more education money invoke
the Insurrection act make an attempt to
federalize the National Guard I feel
like that's a real bad bad idea during
an election year when you're an ex the
most unpopular president since uh Carter
and the economy is
arguably in a a a precarious position I
know that uh there are some people out
there that are making the argument that
the the soft Landing has happened and
that it will continue to uh get better
but I don't know that I'm 100% sold on
that um but but there's still a lot of
bad things that could go bad I don't I
don't know that it makes sense for him
to actually try
to like actually like have the
Insurrection act and like you know cuz
you're going to throw Governor AB Abbot
in federal prison is that what we're
talking about here cuz that's what the
Insurrection act means right doesn't it
well again this is this is what we keep
referencing back to I think and I
maintain this I think I should say I
hope that this thing will end up working
itself out but the escalation everyone
is escalating and it's understand I
understand why every side is escalating
I understand why the evil demons on the
left are escalating I understand why the
right states are escalating I get why
they're all escalating but they're all
escalating and you mentioned Biden's
unpopular he's in an election year but
remember this is a man who is unpopular
within his own party and he has to try
to get that popularity back up or at
least maintain his lame popularity
here's a story from Newsweek Joe Biden
faces growing calls to federalize the
Texas National Guard so of course we had
walking Castro and uh who is the uh the
other guy it was uh Greg quar have
backed calls for the Biden
Administration to federalize se seize
Federal take Federal Federal control of
the Texas National Guard this is one
possible play Joe Biden could make we
have Anthony Michael cre saying Biden
should respond to Greg Abbot by
federalizing the National Guard well
here's from Cornell Law School this is
the National Guard in federal service
call whenever the United States or any
of the Commonwealth weals or possessions
is invaded or is in danger of invasion
by a foreign Nation two there is a
rebellion or danger of a rebellion
against the authority of the government
of the United States or the president is
unable with regular forces to execute
the laws of the United States sounds
like under sections 2 and three Biden
will assert Federal authority over the
Texas National Guard which would be the
best uh
uh look he could do he could do a lot of
things appeases Base by saying we're
going to cut funding but that really
does nothing Biden's strongest move
would be federalizing Texas National
Guard which could instantly ignite a
civil war yeah and what do you do that
here's the risk in that if you're Joe
bid I realize this is all bad right I I
I know it's all bad here's the risk in
that if you're Biden the Texas National
Guard is full of what Texans that's
right what do you do when the Texas
National Guard in a significant portion
if not all of them would say okay no no
in fact we don't work for you anymore we
work for Greg Abbott
what do you do then if you take that
step and you say your National Guard is
mine now and the National Guard says
actually no we're not well now you're
Joe Biden now you have to escalate
further because then you can't say oh
you're right I'm sorry I I I feel bad
about that now you've got to ratchet it
up a notch what does that look like what
happens if Biden tries to federalize
Louisiana and he says there is the
danger of a rebellion against the
authority of the United States coming
out of Texas and with our regular forces
we are unable to execute the laws of
these United States therefore I am
calling for the federalization of the
Louisiana National Guard to assist us in
securing the
Border well good luck with those cions
they're not going to join either those
are the most rebellious people in the
country You' been in Louisiana they're
not joining either that's the problem
they're not going to join they're not
going to be federalized this is the risk
you may end up
with a lot of people in the Texas
National Guard they're going have to
make a decision the United States as a
federal government or or your home state
and this is a question asked by the the
Confederate generals that they asked
themselves they they wrote letters about
it why this was a question asked by the
colonists too right these people these
people in the Confederacy were trained
at West Point they had traveled all over
the country they had served in war for
the United States in various lands Lee
was better degraded than Grant right and
now they all fought together in the
Mexican-American War that's right and
then they were asked the federal
government or your home and they said I
have no choice I choose my home that's
what Lee said do do you know why the uh
Southerners were fought the Civil War
the southerners do you know why the
southerners fought the Civil War no do
you know why the southerners fought the
Civil War they were invaded because they
were invaded they were I remember like
it was yesterday I was watching a
something with Shelby foot I think it
was actually he's so interesting yeah
they but they were asking him about it
and they he was going over uh the Union
Soldiers had run into a farmer in
Tennessee and they said hey what what
are you fighting us for you don't have
any slaves what do you care about that
and he said why am I fighting you you're
down here you're in Tennessee what what
are you doing here that's the reason the
Confederacy fought was very complicated
and largely had to do with escalation of
conflict pertaining to the expansion of
slavery yeah uh Fort Sumpter sovereignty
but why did the average Southerner feel
that they should enlist to join the
ranks well there's a lot of conscription
don't get me wrong but where was the
morale they did not go to them and say
only 5% of the population owned slaves
very small number of slave owners the
average other did not own slaves the
overwhelming majority of them did not
own slaves but when the union came in
and started by force saying you are
under our boot they easily go to a farm
boy and say protect your
home and they said okay but and I don't
think anyone here would argue with this
there is much less of that Affinity to
the state set all the slavery stuff
aside for the time being there's much
less of that Affinity to the state today
than there was before I'm not saying
there's none but there's a lot less of
that now than there was before you
misund understand there's no Affinity to
the state back then either well they
love their states back there state was
their country back then kind of but
that's not the question a person asks
himself the question they ask is your
mom lives up the hill yeah are you going
to wait for her Farm to be burned down
by Union forces because you're provide
she's providing food to the enemy or are
you going to protect your friends and
your family you would try and protect
your mom for sure so the Texas na can't
even believe we're talking about this
this is horrible and it's it's not out
of the realm of Poss it's crazy that
that we're even having this conversation
it is not the state doesn't matter so
much as the state has resources
jurisdiction and uh uh uh combat power
so when it comes to Texas the question
will be when the federal government if
they try to federalize the Texas
National Guard that 19-year-old kid is
going to call his mom and she's gonna
say oh my God I don't know what you
should do what happens if you just go
with Biden I could get arrested
well then don't do that I don't know Mom
if the feds come in it's going to be bad
for everybody and these people are in
the border is a disaster if we if if if
I say okay to Joe Biden our home is gone
our our our our state is in disarray you
know we're going to wake up tomorrow
morning and what we're going to have is
a deal that's done and it is a deal
that's going to be done that each side
will think makes them looks look good
and each side's base will hate them for
it I Abid you know backed away in some
place his base will hate him for it
Biden will hate him for it you watch
it's going to happen tomorrow they're
both going to cave in some way to try to
back off of this thing you watch because
what you're saying if they don't is a
likelihood if they do not I going way I
don't think they will then then you're
saying that the two paths we're looking
we look at right now are civil war or
the the entire collapse of the United
States due to an invasion well yeah
collapse is what they all want collapse
is what they want that's their goal so
when facing you know when you've I i'
I've made this point because I think it
shows the the the severity of the
problem when New York City is when Eric
Adams says this will destroy us I
believe that's a quote yes when uh uh
the mayor of Chicago is having panic
attacks and they're talking about
building internment camps to bring the
migrants when New York's implementing
curfews it is an existential crisis to
to this country thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net